اختبار صعب يدخله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لتتويج عقدين من حكمه في ولايه
رئاسيه جديده واخيرا كما ينص الدستور يدخل
اردوغان الانتخابات بمواجهه سته احزاب
معارضه متحالفه ضده لكن العلاقه القريبه
التي اسسها اردوغان مع القطاع المحافظ تعد
اهم عنصر سانده في السلطه اضافه الى قاعده
حزبيه قويه حلفاء الرئيس التركي لجانب
حزبه العداله والتنميه هي احزاب صغيره
لكنها قد تحسم السباق الانتخابيه المتقارب
لتضمن له تجاوز عتبه الخمسين بالمئه في
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات منها احزاب
اسلاميه صغيره تجد نفسها تحظى بتاييد
متصاعد خصوصا حزب الرفاه الجديد ورغم ترشح
زعيمه فاتح البكان فانه عاد وانسحب واعلن
صراحه دعمه لاردوغان وكذلك يوجد حزب
الحركه القوميه المتحالف مع اردوغان وساهم
في في السلطه والحفاظ على اغلبيته
بالبرلمان ايضا من ضمن الاحزاب التي تحالف
معها اردوغان حزب الدعوه الحره ينتمي
مؤسسه عرقيا للاكراد ويصنفون ايدولوجيا
اسلاميين محافظين لذا يوصف الحزب عاده
بانه حزب كردي اسلامي
اردوغان رحب بدعم حزب الدعوه الحره حيث
يمنحه هذا الدعم فرصه للحصول على اصوات في
مناطق كرديه كان يخشى ان تكون سببا في
خسارته حزب اليسار الديمقراطي ضمن قائمه
داعمي اردوغان رغم العداء التاريخي فهو
حزب علماني اصيل كان للحزب ثقه له الكبير
منذ عام
1999 عندما حصل على 136 مقعدا في البرلمان
الا انه تدهور بعد وفاه زعيمه بولنت
اجاويد ولم يعد له اي مقعد ادراج هذا
الحزب رغم ضاله تاثيره يبرز غرابه
التحالفات التي دفعت تيارات للاصطفاف
اضطراريا رغم اختلاف الايديولوجيا من اجل
تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات